ils se tiennent par la main comme de
bons élèves
ils se sont d'abord deux adultes qui
roulent en tandem un jeunes inscrits à
la mission locale et une personne
malvoyante
la première fois c'était en angoisse est
un petit peu on a deux
maintenant je connais juste stabilise un
peu le vélo de temps en temps à
l'arrière ce sont sûrement mes petites
roulettes
avec cette initiative de la mission
locale de plaisir deux idées fortes
prendre confiance en soi et chasser les
a priori les jeunes ils ont souvent
pleins d'à priori ils n'osent pas aller
tout simplement par les personnes qui
sont différentes et là c'était vraiment
l'occasion de lever des freins aller
vers l'autre osé poser les questions
une fois toutes les questions posées
c'est parti pour un moment autant
sportif que culturel
ça fait pas une balade ça fait en même
temps de la découverte ça fais ta
culture et ça aussi la mission locale
son coeur de métier c'est bas de faire
accéder à la culture
les jeunes accèdent à la culture
alors c'est pas bien d'ailleurs ça va
arrêter démarrage c'est un peu du retard
il
ça permet de partager entre les jeunes
qui sont souvent mal vu quoi et puis bah
des personnes malvoyantes plus âgés ça
permet de découvrir de nouvelles choses
c'est bon pour nous ça a été la
difficulté de leur faire confiance parce
que déjà en tant que non voyant il faut
toujours faire confiance en son pilote
ce qui est pas évident d'autant quand ce
sont des jeunes qui n'ont jamais fait de
tandem
donc ça a été aussi un petit peu
d'émotion pour nous ça a déraillé en
arrière
c'était la deuxième séance d'une
opération qui porte un joli nom tant
d'émotions à raison de deux lundis par
mois 5 autres échanges sont programmés